[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to the lobby
GameSpot's weekly video game hangout
here in San Francisco California going a
bit late today we had some guests come
in I don't know that we published any
videos yet or said who it was but in the
coming days we'll show off some strong
men some strong some strong wrestlers I
came in that's all I'll say
but anyway we pushed the lobby back to
the old time at 2 p.m. Pacific so if
you're on the East Coast just getting
out of work welcome if you're over here
with us hopefully we didn't close out
the date with you almost everybody else
outside the United States welcomes well
I'm Mike McCarty here as always with
Peter Brown right say hi to the camera
really know the people Rob Hanley hi hi
we got a really full show today have a
giveaway as always I'll get into that
later on in the show
someone fortunate was yesterday a lot of
unfortunate news EA visceral was
shuttered EA also canceled whatever
didn't really cancel the Star Wars game
they were making so much as shuffled
people around to other internal studios
and also they're pivoting that project
to essentially be more games as service
I have the statement here from a Patrick
soderlund and we'll get into that later
start off on a more lighthearted note
with a few news things and we'll get
into evil then to which I'm very much
enjoying now that I played most of it
South Park which Pete Rob and Callie
have tried out Pete's gonna kind of give
us an update on his GG Sport review a
bit of a weird situation there and talk
a little bit more about the game I got a
bunch of Twitter questions yesterday so
we'll get through all those as always
the YouTube and twitch chats are up here
in game spot so feel free to chime in if
you say something funny or make fun of
Rob or anything I will probably call it
out and let's get into it I was just
about saying nice intro and cool that
last part oh sorry
scratch that but thank you cuphead sold
1 million i suck at the game apparently
no I'm just kidding I really like the
game it's one of my favorite games how
we did a reboot upside and people of
course saw the title saying you know the
difficulty with video games
the problem with video game difficulty I
assume by sucked at it but no it's a
very good game
Joey has a lot of good gameplay up on
our YouTube channel he did got an s-rank
on all of the expert mode bosses this
right here is the matchstick something I
forget the full name
random and a P rank pacifist yes yeah
this game is fantastic congratulations
to studio mvhr the moldenhauer brothers
and the rest
people that worked on that team with
them I believe they're toronto-based
either way they sold a million copies
which is great for them great for
Microsoft has a console exclusive can't
say anything more about that game that
hasn't already been said
fantastic work on their part gorgeous
but also challenging and rewarding in
more ways than one so yeah so also new
Wolfenstein - marketing campaign kind of
kicked off this week I would say as we
lead up to the October 27th release Kali
you'll be reviewing it hopefully you'll
be getting it next week some point
you've been playing through a new order
I know Nick margarita I just played
through new order for the first time and
now like he can't get enough of these
trailers the launch trailer was I think
this is the original III trailer if I'm
not mistaken skal him yeah yeah sorry
they're reusing those alternate history
like television shows and TV programs
it's great yes so then this is like the
resistance call-to-action and everybody
stand up if we see you in the streets
fighting Nazis whether it's with your
fists or with guns you're on our side
it's just getting amped up you see Anya
here who in this point is pregnant with
twins yet she's still sliding past a
group of Nazis forename yeah my queen
why people's life goals just badassery
in general of this game you see that
dual wheeling with different weapons
I honestly and also like not to mention
yeah the 10-second kind of promo the
teaser to this launch trailer Pete Hines
head of Bethesda PR was saying I you
know like the game was not meant to be
social commentary they have written the
according to development for a while
yeah but the marketing campaign was very
prescient in the way that it said
there's only one side and then it showed
the Nazi getting punched says like if
you're not yeah yeah so you know like
that game will be a very real hopefully
cathartic experience on October 27 we
get the chance to play it I do want to
add that one of the notable things about
that trailer is you can kill the KKK
members which for some reason I had
assumed they were just kind of like set
pieces I'm not sure why are like part of
cutscenes uh but you actually see it see
the dude get shot in the face right
after right after the release date that
you know like the actual title screen it
showed Hitler will come out like
stumbling John Luke was getting it super
into like
well like though they the first game how
intentionally set up you running into
him because they said he was sick and
weird and losing it
yeah probably on methamphetamines or
something do you I've read that book
recently actually mine comp oh Jesus
Christ no the author it was the one it's
explored how much the like Third Reich
was using drugs and what night it got a
lot of pushback saying oh so you're
excusing them saying no not at all I'm
saying
meth was a huge thing in the Third Reich
in the Wehrmacht I saw I think for like
soldiers at large yeah yeah wait
actually oh for sure yeah I have no idea
but anyway welcome sign to the new
Colossus October 27th alongside Super
Mario Odyssey and Assassin's Creed
origins a great day crazy day but it'll
be fun
we we were talking about strange things
- yeah very right we were talking about
that last shot Hitler I don't know if it
was confirmed but like I think was a
good giant bomb interview with one of
the I think creative director for what
the new Wolfenstein
kinda machine games yeah kind of tease
that you had the shot here one that like
you know in order for Hitler to be alive
in this late 60s right he needs to be
like cry out or like you know reborn
more or less but very you know we're
just not not killing himself right in
the bunker we looked like it's riddle oh
he looks I thought he looked you would
be about 70 anyways but I don't know but
the ending of the first Wolfenstein had
mecha Hitler right right
we were just talking the office for a
while I think the third game which is
confirmed they're doing a third game yes
well then yeah it is it's got to amount
to that final boss you know I mean like
you'll I don't think you're gonna fight
Hitler in this game is what I'm getting
at no like inglourious basterds kind of
release scene I mean how can you top
that as I'm saying for a trilogy my top
like Hitler Mecca hit the apex of like
yeah that's exciting another Bethesda
news the doom doom on switch got its
official release date November 10th we
get to check that out in Nintendo's
handheld slash live
kind of consul I hear ya we got the we
got a lot of traffic on this video we
put this up Nick and Miguel were over
there checking this out got some over
the shoulder footage is this Nick
playing I believe that my team I shot
this I want to rushed over there and
then unbuttoned my shirt to hide the
glare later on I won my shirt this guy
means steady hands I was impressed he
was one of the developers you do too
holding the camera but I'll try pon
I did not okay I'm curious how a
first-person shooter like dual analog
will feel on a handheld of course you
can always play this with a program on
TV but I think the appeal for me is
playing a handheld yeah I don't know
that I would play doom right before bed
but I also would I yeah I would just say
it's like I don't know if I would
recommend playing it right before bed
but that is a hundred percent something
I would do I really really like this
game a whole lot I'm not very excited I
already bought it I'll probably buy it
again for switch ya know so that's
November 10th and then I don't believe
the Wolfenstein 2 version on switch
which comes out 2018 hasn't released a
yet maybe sometime late spring I don't
know if I'm guessing I told some guy
this morning that he's wrong that gaming
coming to switch then I was like around
the same time but they should they oh is
it they released another trailer or
whatever but it was also same time
wasn't it they said both games was it
yeah now I thought they announced both
games
yeah they announced them both times but
then they said doom was coming this year
Wolfenstein will be after the fact next
year they show doom but no it's the same
yeah I was the same I don't know if it
was an event or just some sort of like
announcement thing that organized cool
that's pretty much it for news Pete you
text me they're not saying hey we should
talk about the new Xbox Dashboard which
I got to check out I have looked at it
you oh it's it's surprisingly functional
half the deal with Playstation from from
my personal standpoint I think
Playstations menu UI whether you're
going through the games the PlayStation
Store through any of your video TV apps
it's very functional it's pretty much
just rows and then you
down and you want more details
functional but intuitive thank you
that's a better way to describe it
it's ui/ux works very well Xbox is more
like that so you start off and this is
your home screen you go you've got the
games and apps right here on that row
underneath here it shows like what's
happening right now like you're
downloading Gears of War for your here's
your friends row it still looks a little
cluttered it's that whole you know like
Windows 10 weird kind of asymmetrical
grid doesn't even make sense with a very
yeah looks like it's supposed to be a
touchscreen and though this is not a
touchscreen kind of deal right and
getting there just but it's better the
thing is is like okay sorry just
interject real quick appreciation UI
works so well because you know here
games here are all the settings and like
secondary things I want to take care of
the secondary things still seem to be
out of the way yeah they are and they
aren't so you just hit the home button
and I found that the like scrolling
through that menu was easier and I mean
does a very minor change but it's kind
of like a sidebar that pops up and
they've been slowly transitioning from
like kicking you to the dashboard when
you hit the home button anyway um but I
I did find it a little a little easier
to navigate I mean the I it's still not
a girl I still don't love it right now
but at least they're trying it does I
mean I've been actually using my xbox a
lot over the last few weeks and half the
problem with the old UI for me was that
I just didn't use Xbox enough to get the
muscle memory but this is definitely
more intuitive than it used to be it it
does feel more like I know if I'm on a
certain page I get why this page exists
rather than oh there's a code you redeem
a code in this weird corner I could play
a game in this weird corner here's how I
get to Netflix it's way more it makes
more sense now and I've been playing
evil in two and cuphead and what's the
last one I've been playing South Park
era I was gonna play South Park and Xbox
but I downloaded it recently and so I've
actually been using it more I'm getting
more muscle memory with it and I like it
a lot more I wonder why they didn't do
this three years ago I feel like this is
what the well I guess the current or
last UI wait this is now implemented
this okay yes two days ago cool the last
one I feel like it was it was super
relying on like buttons and triggers
like
in order to pull up your games I think
it was like right trigger and that in
itself is like is too demanding you know
what I mean where it's like it's it's a
menu I should be able I should be able
to see at a glance yeah like I mean I
should just be able to use the stick and
get anywhere as quickly as possible
I think the triggers were both like you
know settings and like all these things
so yeah when you did load it up I don't
know I just never got the hang of it
it's so like image-heavy I mean
PlayStation is just these like uniform
squares with that PlayStation font all
of this is all the individual you know
like you still see the cover art in the
squares on the game but then you go down
into it and it's everything you know you
go to keep TV inapt it's the PlayStation
or it's the TV that like Sony designed
or whatever it just makes it's more
uniform and cohesive I would say I I do
also like the like pinning a game works
more smoothly on this like I was trying
next I've been playing Wolfenstein new
order through again but before new
Colossus and I've been playing that on
Xbox playing Southpark next box also and
I was just pinning those things because
my pins are pretty outdated I mean the
first destiny pin and stuff like that
and I did find that easier and like
scrolling through that was better and
finding like the things that I wanted to
the apps I wanted to use right away like
Netflix crunchyroll yeah and then like
whatever game I'm playing so that's yeah
they're getting there I think wow and
the YouTube chat was saying man this
just makes me appreciate the simplicity
of switches UI even more yeah I love
this which is like an even more basic
PlayStation almost prettier yeah also I
mean the biggest I think I don't have
you guys ever said I've been like yeah
just having the last you I just had the
store right like two-thirds of the
screen was like was like an ad it was
just like yeah it's no here so you go to
store and then the redeem code thing is
much easier now that used to be a pain
that's like a problem for us more than
most normal people
definitely has been absolutely I would
definitely say this upgrades the Xbox
Dashboard from like a D to a C+ B -
maybe there you go yeah they're getting
what what's going on now and I don't
know it was like library Layard this is
also probably not a widespread thing but
it was also easier to look at your
achievements and I like that yeah yeah
he's a Syracuse alum interesting little
tidbit hi it looks like you're trying to
load up cup it is incredibly easy to
turn on the voice not the voice commands
but like I'm assuming - yes it's a very
creepy voice as well it's not Larry's it
is this is like tinsel robot that says
games and apps mixer community playing
the evil within - and I didn't know how
to turn it off because I don't even know
how I turn it on all you do is press the
Guide button and then press Start that's
how that's why I was so easy cuz I'm
trying to get out of it so I press Start
and all of a sudden this weird man was
in my bedroom cool so again if you
haven't updated your xbox recently if
you plan on using it soon update to that
dashboard it's much better in my opinion
it looks like you're trying to load up
cuphead let me show you the store first
there's a tutorial to get into the
game's tutorials now Pete yes a bit of a
weird kind of curious situation going on
with GT sport you've been playing it a
little bit before so it's out as of it's
out yesterday yes there Tuesday the 17th
yeah there was a demo out last week that
gave me access to a lot of modes in the
game so the bottom line is there are
reviews out for this game however we
will not be publishing a review until
November because it's like a super
unique situation in terms of how the
game was designed almost yeah I mean
it's always it's it's always been out
there that GT sport is a competitive
game first and foremost but it is also
sort of positioned itself as having
single-player content to go with it well
now the game is out the single-player
content is pretty shallow it's not that
long and really what it does is it
serves despite being called a campaign
it's really just training to teach you
how to get better at driving and how to
understand understand
a little bit better and what is training
you for are these championships and
these championships don't kick off until
early November hence why we're waiting
and everything sort of feeds into your
progress as a player which will then
determine how you are ranked where you
are placed when these Championships
begin and there's a few different things
that sort of dictate that one of them
being the sportsmanship ranking and then
this is a point that you know it also
makes me consider is this game ready for
a review because basically what this
does is it tracks how you act on the
track with other drivers around you and
will sort of say oh he's a polite driver
he's responsible or he's a pain in the
ass chaotic bastard and they will sort
of group people together now one of the
concerns I have is that you know if you
hit someone obviously you should be
penalized for that if someone hits you I
don't think that it's necessarily your
fault but the game will treat it as
though you are part of the problem so
right now there's a lot of questions in
terms of like okay this game goes
through all these hoops to make you a
polite driver but does it actually
enforce that or is it sort of this
communion you know supposed to encourage
the community to enforce it they can you
know it's up to the players to be good
people because if everyone's a [ __ ]
it's not gonna make any difference
mmm-hmm which is usually the case well I
think the community behind this game is
very passionate and is very
knowledgeable about why these rules are
in place and they are and they're you do
see people who try their best and
succeed at being polite you also see
people who are jerks and unfortunately
that can immediately ruin a race and
that can also you know ruin your chances
for placing in these tournaments so
there are a few things at play most
notably being that the you know the
things that this game is presenting
haven't had enough time to really be
tested to the extent that they demand
you to take them seriously so I you know
I will say this game has an it feels
incredible behind the wheel I really
love racing in this game I'm a little
disappointed by the lack of
single-player content like that said I'm
also very impressed with the sort of
ambitious mission that politically
digital and Sony have set out for this
game which is you know to make it a
essentially a racing eSport that's
governed by a real world racing
organization like the
one out there and I don't think that's
really been done before and it could be
something really special and really cool
but it's not clear yet if we could if
that is successful and given that this
game is sort of you know geared towards
that tract alone at the moment I really
don't know that we can issue a review
and give people our clear understanding
of whether or not this game succeeds I
can give a personal recommendation about
is what's there good right now but it's
filled with caveats it's filled with you
know exceptions and buts but you think
it is worth checking out right now if
you're not but yep assuming if you just
want a single-player experience don't
buy this game just you know if you
you're recommending now for people who
want to get into the hole for
tournaments eSport kind of stuff we want
to take it as more seriously than any
other racing game out there except with
the exception of sorry I've like I
racing like I racing is probably the
only other series that really demands as
much not just performance but you know
navier-- and commitment and stuff like
that and on the note of commitment it's
a little disappointing to see some of
the confusion surrounding the
competitive aspects that are enabled in
the game right now so you can get into
lobbies with people you can make your
own Lobby there's no automatic
matchmaking so like trying to find a
casual race with other people is pretty
tough but every 20 minutes you're
guaranteed to hop into one of three I
hate this daily races and these a cycle
every 20 minutes one race opens up after
another that part's fine it's you know
in the in the the mindset of hey I'm
trying to training it better at these
tracks I'm trying to you know whatever
learn the system and yes advance my
profile both as a driver and responsible
sportsman that's fine but the problem is
these daily races are not refreshed
daily oh when they sit precisely when
they say daily what they mean is you can
play these every day you should you
should play these every day
Wolfenstein 2 is also a daily game yeah
precisely so it almost sounds like
they're refreshed weekly that is the
plan it's any good three tracks I and
again fixed intervals 20 good idea maybe
EA should take a page out there but can
make that Star Wars game kind of
somewhere
look I don't want to disparage what gran
turismo is trying to do but I do want to
hold off our review until I can say
whether or not they've succeeded okay
well isn't there also yesterday you were
playing you were waiting for 10 minutes
in a lobby and then you're gonna get in
the race and you didn't have the right
thing to race I just warned you yeah I
waited about 15 minutes to get into a
race it was a this wasn't part of the
daily races section this was part of the
Lobby system where I was trying to join
someone's Lobby I got in and I'm you
know they need 16 people so I'm waiting
and waiting and waiting for 16 people to
join that finally happens and then it
gets to the next screen it's like oh
yeah you need dirt tires you don't have
any cars with dirt tires sorry you're
out
the game could have told me that ahead
of time I could not let me into that
race ahead of time because the
parameters are set before you create a
Lobby so there are a few you know little
issues I think the game has some silly
qualities but you know they don't really
impact the idea of racing which again
this game feels excellent behind the
wheel I'd I've tried playing project
cars on Ford so recently I enjoy Forza
you know maybe more than project cars
but when it comes down to the actual
feel of racing Gran Turismo is at the
moment my favorite I'm not a hardcore
sim racing guy mm-hmm but I have played
Gran Turismo
since the beginning and the game is as
good as it's ever been on the track
people are asking being a racing game
they can't tell through the stream as
much because I've been coding and
whatnot has this game look in-game so
right now I've been playing it on 1440p
monitor on a Playstation pro with
quality over a frame rate and it's not
an HDR monitor I've heard incredible
effort that this is like one of the best
games for HDR out there I haven't seen
that yet unfortunately
but I will say cars look amazing replays
look really good
the environments are less impressive
than I hope that's where I mean again
from our feet here and I'm sure for the
stream is like yeah like vegetation
looks a little stiff there's no there's
no like weather or light cycle you
basically will play a track at like a
fixed time of day and the lighting is
fixed as well so you don't get too much
dynamic let you get a lot of like
dynamic reflections like off of cars and
stuff like that but it's not like you're
seeing like the Sun like pass over the
clouds or anything to that effect so the
lighting is pretty sterile in a lot of
ways
and there's also like you know any track
that has buildings on it the buildings
look very flat but again I've seen some
screenshots in HDR and I'm like this
looks like the way that this game was
meant to be played
it was developed with that first in mind
as far as I can tell so outside of HDR
it does leave something to be desired
but when you're driving hundred forty
miles per hour that's it's also not a
major concern of mine I don't I don't
worry about that too much it sounds
really good it's got an excellent sound
it's so weird the state of this game
right now not that it's the game itself
is unfinished but it almost like it's
not ready to be played as it was meant
to be played I would say well so that's
the thing right is as it's meant to be
played is you know they have this system
that that needs to have organic sort of
segmentation of the audience and that
does take time if they if they just had
a championship right now mm-hmm
that would feel weird because everyone
would just be in the same pool and they
would be as chaotic as it feels today
the day after launch yeah a couple weeks
from now if that system works as
intended things should be better and
that to me is the right time to launch
that part of it I will say the singer
put single-player content the way that
it's pitched within the game is is
dubious because it's really not a
campaign as much as it really is
training yeah a campaign means something
different to me which is not a list of
challenges that puts you in very hyper
specific scenarios and test your ability
to complete those things that you know
very specific when is it time it's weird
I'm not much of a racing game fan but I
was optimistic about this at least from
as an outsider looking in because we had
a cousin or cousin or no cousin or a
Yamauchi the creator of the series from
polyphony he came on our e3 stage to
talk about how they actually because the
game was originally supposed to release
was it earlier this year last year last
year I believe and they delayed it he
said because they want to make sure it's
complete when they release it which who
knows what that means I really don't
know I just assume like it would be yeah
like by whose standards right yeah but
what standards I guess right you know
one of the weird things is the car
selection is very slim right now it's
it's 250 you said no home no it's about
160 but that includes multiple like
sometimes up to four variants of the
same car with which single manufacturer
which is closer to like 80 it's a set
screw yes you know II mean wise I mean
to say a number but it's like the only
difference is what like a spoiler one
like said car well I mean there's
there's lots of different tuning
involved and and the thing is is that
these cars are based on real-world
builds so for the right person these
cars may feel distinct yeah but I think
it takes a sort of an elevated passion
and knowledge base to really see what's
there and appreciate it for what it is
now again I'm not a sim racer but I can
appreciate what's in there but I think
even if you were a sim racer you might
not know the difference between five
different Lancers that no one was shown
at the Geneva Auto Commission and almost
like that's all that's all really cool
factoids and I'll and I like the idea
that the game can be so nuanced but in
practice it doesn't feel like I'm
there's an appreciable difference
between the rewards I'm getting that
being cars they should just put like
another hundred cars but in loot crate's
you know winning I'll stop one of the
fun things about Gran Turismo in the
past was the idea that you could you
could ride a car that had and I said it
in my stupid preview everyone hates that
has more care has more character than
horsepower you know what I mean for fun
it's not about being the best racer in
the fastest racing class in the world
it's literally just about engaging with
automobiles in a way that you find
perhaps relaxing but you can still be
competitive so I think even though
they're going for this really serious
thing with GT sport which is totally
cool it wouldn't hurt to also have a
more casual competitive environment as
well so when I think of a complete game
I think of something that can cater not
to every audience because if you try to
be that democratic you'll never get
anything out but at least something to
you know if you're going to have a
single-player mode quote-unquote
campaign back that up show that there is
something for the person who doesn't
strive to be the number one Gran Turismo
clear-rite
the casual just wants to relax a little
bit yeah even if that means racing
against others online that you can get
go-karts that's the thing that was in I
think it started with six might have
been flawed halogen golf cards for a sec
well I mean I thought I mean of course
you can take it too far I think Gran
Turismo 6 had a moon rover that you
could drive on the moon in zero gravity
and tip over with the smallest mistake I
mean that's cool it's cool in theory
it's a it's a bit like ok this is beyond
the scope of the game maybe it's not
necessary and I don't think something
like that is necessary here but
realistic too huh it's not very Rihanna
Houston Houston
downshift
take a breather sorry I'm done I was
gonna ask I don't know if you've already
touched on it or not but did you
mentioned like the the turn tournaments
and how they work or does championships
aren't they like set times of day or
like yes or like November 3rd November
4th November 7th are the three upcoming
championships and then what happens
after that then I just then I wait two
more - anyways then you practice some
more and you wait and then it's what
your bit then it's the game that you're
describing right now yeah I mean it's
sort of back to this back to this phase
sounds like waiting for an iron banner
except way less to do in the interim
that's essentially the reductive West I
don't like to be relevant I guess that
essentially makes sense I mean as a
single player you basically only have
the ability to unlock cars and improve
your skill the game hands out cars
pretty readily and again if the cars
aren't that different you start to sort
of feel this apathy from one car to the
next it doesn't really feel like a
significant change in your experience
it's still a Prius even though you put a
right red spoiler on it I wish there was
a prison look what's the time frame of
like the next like are they saying like
every month there no that they haven't
said and that they do have a calendar in
the game but it doesn't show anything
beyond the first three championships
which are the same way what if I'm on
vacation those three days like in real
life I mean real drivers don't go on
vacation I mean that is this is this
your job now this is the mentality right
I mean it's it's the same reason why
they push sportsmanship to be so
seriously because in the real world you
wouldn't hedge someone off the track and
potentially risk their life and it's a
million-dollar car you wouldn't do that
and so why would you do it here likewise
if you're serious about this you make
yourself available and I think Kazunori
Yamauchi like fulton recovering you out
of a resort in hawaii to bring you back
here to Train II's dangling keys I do
want to ask and this might be an
irritating question but bear with me
what would you say to people who are
like well if that's not what if that's
not you if you don't want to be a
serious racer then why not play Forza or
project cars yeah no if you don't want
to be if you don't want to be a serious
racer I wouldn't recommend this game
right but like I mean like I personally
really like games that can scale the
challenge in the
of activities to kind of each person's
individual play style I like when
there's more to do than just one way to
play a game consider this consider this
like legal League of legacy the hell
League of Legends
consider this like dota I mean this is
there's a very high barrier to success
here yeah and there really isn't any
concern for lowering that beyond hey you
guys drive like [ __ ] you drive
together and leave us to do the real
racing right now there is sort of like
this pitch down the road the oh no we're
gonna beef up the single-player campaign
yada yada yada
yamo use words when that's coming if
it'll cost anything what it will entail
it's difficult to say there may come a
time when this game can do that but
presently that's not the case in my
experience but yeah I guess what I'm
getting at is like what look is there
necessarily anything wrong with that or
is that just are we just talking in
terms of the review and like
recommending it to two people I mean
right now I'm discussing I guess the
reasons why I'm not reviewing it today
right and perhaps giving a PSA for
anyone who might think that Oh Gran
Turismo I know Gran Turismo yeah your
past experience doesn't really inform
what's going on I drove that rover on
the moon it's a very different game now
in that regard so review sometime in the
coming weeks once you've got a better
handle or like once you actually try it
out tournaments and multiplayer updates
and whatnot yeah daily weekly races
right I mean so like the game gives you
sort of like a daily workout regimen
which requires about 90 minutes or so to
pass and you can do that in various ways
and every day yeah you don't have to
it's really just like a mile count how
much road you cover it's like a sony
fitbit sure and and you know in that
regard I have enjoyed since the demo
picking it up and playing it for a
little bit and I have seen improvements
in my skill I have not seen a reflection
of my efforts to be a polite racer and
still win races pay off and any sort of
advancement with the online profiles
which is a little disappointing if I'm
honest because I am doing my best I am
seeing people not try their best and
it's impacting me in a way that is
presently held me back from advancing
out of that pool I mean I feel like
that's actually more of a big deal than
it even sounds because that's like a
main core conceit of the tournament
structure is yeah
is how sportsmen like you are precisely
but you know I don't know if a couple
days is enough time for that system to
sort of do its thing and ultimately it's
really going to result in the
championship stuff and like if I had you
know if I put forth an honest effort to
get there to get to that point and it
doesn't feel like it was worth it
and I don't mean it I don't get first I
mean it doesn't feel like the things
that I was hoping for relative to my
skill are there they'll be a problem
I'm also have to consider if it's worth
if it's something I can do because I
have to manage all the reviews on site
and do other reviews as well so right
now the plan is for me to review it that
may change as time develops but
ultimately we are going to wait till
November to publish our review and that
will be once these systems get the time
they need cool so GT sport is out now
but we will have along with a few other
sites a more concrete opinion once we
get to try that stuff out in the coming
weeks as November kicks off I want to
get into the evil within - before we get
to South Park and then the unfortunate
visceral closing evil within - I played
I think I'm on chapter 10 now out of 17
I believe if I'm not mistaken this game
is a not a so I read through alesandro's
review I liked it but I still didn't
really I don't know I wasn't super amped
for it because I liked the first one the
first one I had 15 chapters and I always
tell everybody I love the first 10 hate
the last five that's when like on Rails
turret sequences kick in a very bad
final boss fight really dumb kind of
obscure puzzle solving this game is I
like it a lot
obviously Shinji Mikami of Resident Evil
Fame is the executive producer on this
he founded a tango gameworks who makes
these games and then bethesda publishing
them Sebastian Castellanos still not the
best voice acting still not the best
written story at all but the game itself
the way it's structured it's just all
these sandbox environments where the
survival aspect matter way more because
it's a one big environment where you're
going between objectives and doing mini
side quests and it's almost like if you
took the village from the beginning of
resonable 4 and expanded that into like
a bunch of these sand boxes or there was
like a village survival part in the
first evil than which I think that is
that game at its best if you did the
Marguerite boss fight and resonable 7
yes not no but sorry I like to dress a
spider spider lady when you're fighting
her it's kind of this open-ended
environment where you to fight but I'm
playing more this game and it's Nick
margarita and Jake we're both talking
about yesterday how it's it's clunky and
I agree and it's very it feels like The
Last of Us this the suburban
environments where you're kind of can go
stealth or even the way you upgrade
yourself and your weapons and crafting
is all similar but I like it a lot
I've like reduced my weapon sway with
upgrades there's a lot to find obviously
there Easter eggs like other Bethesda
properties you can find corporal itano's
masks of vault-tec vaultboy a bobblehead
but i really really like it
it does give me like flashbacks to resin
before of course third-person kind of
over-the-shoulder survival horror this
survival I really want to play in the
classic mode there you only get seven
saves and there's no Auto saving so
that's more like save rooms from the
earlier Resident Evil games jean-luc I
think is starting that I don't know how
far he's gotten but me and him are
pretty stoked about that because we're
we're both survival horror fans and I
know John Luke played resonable 7 on the
madhouse difficulty I think survival
horror games are very good I'm their
hardest difficulties I think that's when
they really get their you know tenets
across coffee of course refills your
health all the way whatever they take
some throat cuts yeah it's a very Twin
Peaks thing and I've seen also the that
it looks like the room the Red Room it's
called the red cabin oh yeah no that's
there's a very Twin Peaks in this game
as well yeah you got this the
letterboxing here when you go back to
beacon mental hospital so it's all
taking place like in this psychological
environment again the writing is very
it's weird it starts off like it's very
serious and I'm like this is dumb but
then it gets self-aware enough so last
night I finally if you play dressing
before not to keep making that
comparison but you play dressing before
you know the shooting range and the
bottle cap system there's a shooting
range in this as well and if you get
like the highest score enough points to
get the highest reward like 10,000 green
gel to upgrade your character or 2,500
weapon parts tatiana the nurse will say
Sebastian you're the best around and
he'll be like nothing's gonna ever keep
me down and I'm like what that makes me
want to die I know the game becomes way
more self-aware and dumb about itself
like when you write here actually this
part no not this part but you walk out
of this one building looking for the
villain and he's like now I just need to
figure out where he went and then he
looks up in the sky at this giant spider
thing he's like I think I just figured
it out there are some creepy parts to
it's nothing revolutionary as far as it
goes but it's creepy go ahead run oh I
wasn't saying like I've been hearing I I
get scared I get scared
I get scared pretty easy and that's why
I don't know somebody scared there's
something about I just don't want to
like put up myself through it sometimes
I mean I can handle it but I hear this
game is not as scary as maybe people
were led to believe or no it's more
there are some jump scares but I
wouldn't say it's anything horrible it's
not like brezin evil 7 was creepier
scarier silent hill's obviously it was
PT was way scarier but this is more
about the over-the-shoulder kind of
survival action mm-hmm with a little bit
of horror dressing the villain is
essentially sander Cohen from Bioshock
the one is that the sander Cohen at Fort
frolic who takes all the photos of the
dead people as art sure that's that's
wrong your autobiographical memory or
Jude Law from Road to Perdition sander
Cohen sander Cohen right okay cool thank
you John Luke yeah he that's Fort for
all like one of the better parts in
Bioshock right and he that's kind of the
villain here I mean I do like that that
concept but I I want to go back to
talking about like the resemblance or
the similarities to residue before and
like the Last of Us what I mean you're
pretty far in it sounds like or maybe a
little more than halfway yeah how does
it does it feel like can contrived or or
does it feel like it it lends a fresh
perspective to those things because it's
like I loved The Last of Us
I don't need another game to try to be
the Last of Us right I
love survival horror but it's a genre
that can get very you know I've seen
paint-by-numbers it can be wrote in this
game sure I think the way I would
describe it is if you play rezzing
before and love the village scene and
love the fort scene where you're kind of
surviving with it in the sandbox or if
you played The Last of Us and rather
than something very linear where you're
going from one area to the next you were
kind of you are given the time to
explore and find many side quests if you
like that you will love this game
because this game is essentially from
what I've played just one of those after
the other you can spend four hours here
in town square for hours at City Hall
that's over exaggerating you won't spend
that much time there randomly there will
be side quests yeah she's kind of I
don't know Alessandro I think it was
John Luke maybe I might be putting words
in his mouth we're all talking and we're
all finding stuff and doing side quests
that like the other people didn't which
is cool because the first game was very
linear more you know these chapters are
kind of misleading because two chapters
will take place within like this first
town square sandbox in a it's not
crimson city anymore it's Union but
again it's all this you know like it's
it's been said in the trailer
Sebastian's looking for his daughter
there's optional yeah and finding like
you I mean ostensibly you could not get
the sawed-off shotgun at least as far as
I am and I like took the time do all the
side stuff the crossbow is more apparent
and that's like the famous crossbow from
the first game with exploding both smoke
cold shot bolts harpoons the sawed-off
shotgun I just kind of came across
within like the underground network that
is like the back end like the matrix of
the the place you're in the I forget the
name of it it's like a an animus from
the stem the stem thank you but it's
it's great I liked it a lot
I'm enjoying it now that we I played
much more of it over the weekend mm-hmm
I don't know do you guys get the
transplant even I really want it's a
sort of game my girlfriend would love to
watch me play yeah you all play games
would be necessarily but she likes
watching me play some and I really want
to play that with her yeah yeah I'm just
too expensive right now yeah yeah that's
my biggest problem there's a lot of
games that are competing for my
attention and I just because
I don't know what what I've heard about
not that like I disagree with like the
things that you like about it I just
like what I've heard about it has not
captured me in a way that's like okay
and you just set aside the other things
I'm playing to make time for this if
that makes sense yeah I will say I think
if you like the first game we'd have a
question here from Redfield on Twitter
nice Britt Redfield on Twitter Redfield
70 X 7 pretty constant friend of the
show said is a playthrough a playthrough
of the evil within prior to jumping in
on the second recommended what level
continuity we're talking here thank you
I don't think so I think it I don't come
to this game for the story so I don't
think that's my main priority and also
because the entire first game I hate to
say this it's not really a spoiler
because the trailer for the second game
says you're looking for Lily your
daughter essentially the first game you
think she died in this fire and that's
what he's grappling with at this mental
hospital and now in the second game
they're just taking the first game and
making it even more batshit crazy so I
don't think that's necessary I think
like any sequel it will help if you
played the predecessor yeah it's almost
sequel that just pretty much threw the
entire first not the entire plot but
like the ending out the womb like just
retconning the ending list where it's
like I'll remember all this well
nevermind that's enough exposition more
than enough exposition in the evil
within to to supplement your lack of
familiarity with the first so you could
read like a plot synopsis on Wikipedia
and then jump right in yes and if you
played The Last of Us resi before even
like dead space to some degree which
we'll get to later on the show yeah you
this will be familiar to you but like I
said if you like those open-ended
sandbox environments from those games
this is just that times 10 so nothing
revolutionary at all but it's it's an
iteration on that and that's why I'm
enjoying it and like any survival game
it's just hard to put down but if you're
not like coming up to a huge story beat
there's like tons of stuff to scavenge
and it's very well paced guy little
scavenging it's my favorite I love
looting what's in this crate maybe like
a legendary
no evil into I highly recommend it
Alessandra already has he put up his
review in GameSpot last week early last
week maybe even two weeks ago at this
point it came out October 13 we could
never be sure
well we were gonna talk about last week
but we hadn't fully played it I want to
say it was Thursday the review went up
Thursday corrects so last week Thursday
but that's up on GameSpot up on YouTube
video review if you wanna go check that
out go read that to get more in-depth I
know John Luke and Joey both did like an
Easter Egg video and John Luke's working
on I think at some point you're gonna
lose doing a couple episodes of a show
coming up I don't know if he wants me to
tease him or not 3d Mario history of and
Wolfenstein 1 so if he didn't want me to
I just did anyways sorry John Luke but
he's also working on like a classic mode
which is seven saves period at these
stations harder enemies more survivable
focus and I really want to play that
when I have time evil Vinci was great
surprisingly I do also want to kind of
segue into EA's pivot recently with
visceral came up yesterday I believe on
click soul I think it was Brian Corsetti
the first one to start that published
something about the patent that
Activision filed back in 2015
yeah I'm not really so let me pull this
up right um let me fill you in so the
headline feels like so was Activision
researched using matchmaking tricks to
sell in-game items basically using
players as advertisers right so as they
described it here's the if you're
watching live right now or on YouTube
you could see the article right here
again this is by Brian Corsetti over at
click silver link stones a gaming site
Activision was granted a patent this
month for a system that uses to convince
people in multiplayer games to purchase
items for a game through
microtransactions Activision did tell
Glick so that the technology is not
currently in any game so to clarify just
for be more published purposes I think
we'll have Call of Duty World War two up
any number of Activision titles but
again just to double down this system is
not in use in any current activision
games that they told Glick cyl but and
Bungie also confirmed the Glacial that
the technology is not being used in
destiny too
but to describe the system it
essentially like you just said was that
you or you Pete you just said that they
kind of use I say that was you know you
better
I say a better player kills you it's
almost like you mentioned in a
Battlefront - you were saying like if
like a TIE fighter blows you up and then
you see that has three legendary cards
this system essentially has the
capability to purposely pair you with
very very good players with good loot to
encourage you to be like ah [ __ ] I feel
like I'm missing out I feel like I'm
it's not a level playing field it will
purposely pair you with marquee players
according to the wording in the patent
first of all you can get jealous yes yes
and then you'll feel the need to pay so
according to Activision in the patent it
says for example in one implementation
the system may include a micro
transaction engine that arranges matches
to influence game related purchases for
instance the micro transaction engine
may match a more expert slash marquee
player with a junior player and to
encourage that junior player to make
game related purchases of items
possessed or used by the Marquis /
expert player a junior player may AB
junior player may wish to emulate that
player by obtaining weapons or other
items used by that player so it was what
you were afraid of with Battlefront - if
you said they're showing that's what
that's what battlefront - I can't you
know we can't say that battlefronts who
implements this system but on the chant
in the case that a much better player
kills you and you see they have three
legendary cards that's essentially what
would happen with this system except on
purpose on the game's exactly it's like
an algorithm like I mean this this could
happen right now with so many games yeah
well yeah this is this article is just
or this patent is saying that like we're
gonna enforce it which is crazy think
cuz it's so counterintuitive yeah where
so many games have been frustrating like
I think one example I can't remember but
like titanfall kind of had this problem
where I felt like I was getting
consistently paired up with like really
good players and hope you know you'd
like to think the next match okay you
kind of played like [ __ ] let's play with
some other shitty people like yeah but -
whatever really good matchmaking soon as
tuned implements that pretty well yeah
unless you're playing with like a friend
who's really high level then you might
get your ass kicked but but that's all
isn't that aesthetic stuff because it's
mainly cosmetic it I mean it the
emphasis is on looking good I think in
splatoon but you do have specific
abilities and it'll tell you what you
got killed I mean a lot of games tell
you what you got killed with yeah like
that's that's not new at all the problem
here is that it's the it would be on
purpose to to make you buy something but
I guess like I mean honestly like
normally when I play a game and I see
what I got killed with I'm like oh so
that's the meta weapon that's the weapon
everybody's using like in destiny it's
like Oh everyone's using Uriel's gift or
whatever
maite right yeah so but you can get that
without buying it and it's not like it's
gonna be like oh we only put my two
players in this match oh man do you
think you need mighta to be good oh yeah
I'll say it again like oh man when Pao
front comes out and God it's like if
that's gonna be the first thing that
happens the first person that kills me
is a guy flying by in the next wing with
three legendary cards he's like so I
feel like peace out and I haven't even
gotten the slots yet to have cards like
yeah it would be annoying and make you
jealous
Activision yeah Activision told LIXIL
this was an exploratory patent filed in
2015 by an R&D team working
independently from our game studios it
has not been implemented in game there's
one more example that they kind of the
patent mentioned when you see in a
particular example the junior player may
wish to become an expert sniper in a
game for example as determined from the
player profile according to the patent
the microchip microtransaction engine
may match the junior player with a
player that is a highly skilled sniper
in the game in this man or the junior
player may be encouraged to make game
related purchases such as a rifle or
other item used by the Marquis sniper
player so that's getting into like
really many gritty stuff like based on
your loadouts and across this profile we
know you want to be good at sniping so
we're gonna use that and again this
isn't being user now but this is like a
what essentially saying it could be used
for we know you want to be a good sniper
so we're gonna use that to promote
certain items to you and also put you in
it also says that they could potentially
be put in game types or on maps that
also are very sniper friendly or like
why not just get good
yeah like I just rating
it's really frustrating when like
winning Oh Nate it seems or feels like
you would be good if only you had a
certain weapon right whereas like I know
like we just used the mighta example in
destiny but people like going with green
basic ass weapons and they do well and
it's about skill and that's something
that I liked about the crucible a lot is
that you don't technically need those
things and it actually like I've been
killed by super basic weapons and I was
like okay I guess I me doing that might
a quest wasn't the only thing I needed
to do to win and the idea that like the
thing that upsets me most about this
patent besides the like targeted ads
basically within the game that you
already thought is the idea that this
game the it fits a certain kind of game
design that would make it so you needed
the correct dealer to win which just
just irritates me that just irks me it's
like it's not a skill at all it's
something I always assumed no I'm not
shocked that this exists it's something
I assumed was happening but now like you
see on Facebook obviously targeted ads
across well yes it's not shocking to see
games using it but it's just seeing the
actual patent and reading it in the
patents words and what Activision said
to click so the thing I want now you're
from now you're now you're further
thinking about it yeah that's what is
like the frustrating part of all the
things that we always suspect is that
right the publishers mindset when it
comes to a video game has changed so
dramatically that it's become about this
sort of subtle manipulation versus
funding a great game I mean it's not
news that games are a bigger business
than ever and they're trying to you know
make more money but this is sort of is
like yeah I mean that's this is it on
paper
this is them saying that it exactly it's
a it's like owning up to it I mean
because like games being designed in a
way to make more money is it dates back
to our Cades I mean that's not like a
new thing I mean making a game building
game more difficult to you some money on
it yeah this is like weird like meta
manipulate
I'm just saying like this we know that's
we know that's not new versus like a
different level of like like a good
arcade game can be made difficult but
made difficult in a way that compels you
to want to keep playing exactly it's not
just like oh I died so I feel like I
need to put more money in this right
this is to a different sort of path in
my mind it's a different path I mean
that's what I was getting at it's like
to feel like oh I need to buy something
to get better because no matter how how
much I practice or how much I put into
improving my skill is not going to
matter that's basically what I was
getting at yeah my last question before
we get on to visceral Pete does this in
addition to things with shadow of war
recently four to seven what am I missing
Battlefront 2 which we spoke about last
week on the lobby does this kind of
worry you that again like you just
mentioned this this very well could be
stuff like this is probably being used
in games already but the fact that now
we just see it in writing does this kind
of worry you about stuff going forward
where is it makes me worried for the
people who really like these sort of
games yeah I I'm not huge into
multiplayer competitive stuff like all
the time
so I can easily walk away from something
like this I got plenty of games with
like excellent stories that I can't wait
to interact with things like that so for
me personally I don't think I'm ever
going to run out of good games to play
mm-hmm but I do think is a problem that
will affect a lot of people and will
have a negative impact if this is a
directive that is sort of seen grew and
taken to its logical conclusion it it
worries me when I think about like a 12
year old I think I said last time later
someone someone that's that's literally
like my main concern is like there's
just thirst you know you're 10 you're 12
like you don't own a house you don't
like pay rent
don't don't have a job maybe it's maybe
it's your mom's credit cards but like
there are there are going to be cases
where it's it's just a kid or someone
who is it hasn't you know experience
like were grown up to like manage money
like just realize what this is at face
value right right like understand the
emotions that they're feeling and what
exactly my little brother would have if
this had been around when he was 12 I
mean he would have spent so much money
on this
it would've been a huge problem like I
know that for a fact and luckily he's
just he just missed that because he's
adult now I mean if you're like 21 right
now you have you could have disposable
income to spend on this stuff too and if
you're like even if you know better yeah
because maybe you're you know you're in
college you don't really pay your own
rent in full yet stuff like that you
don't really understand how much money
you start justifying cuz it's you know
at best things it's just a dollar it's
just so it's just a couple dollars and
you know for Battlefront like I said
last time like if there's the past now
well I think they actually resigned that
thought remember earlier out saying oh
because one of the early systems they
said was the legendary the best cards in
the game the legendre is you can only
open or get in a loot crate but I think
they're pulling that back I guess what
I'm saying is like hey if I'm guaranteed
a legendary in this loot crate that's a
win-win that's a dollar cool right like
and then it's like well I'll just get a
couple more it wasn't like you know my
favorite card I mean I'm looking for a
TIE fighter so maybe but a minute $30
$20 I don't know over the course of a
couple months like yes a dollar you know
a dollar day to go back to the Taco Bell
example of last week just think about
how many tacos you could buy with all of
those dollars you're spending and like
right now opposed to like you know
milking a cow and making own cheese hey
you can this taco can be yours for free
but you got to make everything yourself
so right around back here's old Bessie
here's old Bessie yeah no no not old
Bessie here's a baby calf that you need
to first apologies to farmers out there
um cows and cows an Taco Bell I don't
know the thing is people are saying like
do you think this will stop anytime soon
and I was wondering maybe the press is
getting bad enough that Warner Brothers
or Activision or EA will stop it but
holy [ __ ] they make a lot of money off
it
dude and people are growing up on these
kind of games so in like in 10 years it
could be the noir
and like Rose people were just those
people you know those old people on the
porch yelling again they can't like
think about like just like your typical
teenagers flight like are they really
you know digging deep into like
criticisms of games like they know
they're gonna get it the call of duty
they like a Star Wars fan is gonna get
battlefront yeah like card need to buy
this gun card and like you said memorize
the number they like you there is a rut
like that's why yeah they're like
another part of it is like there's that
rush again when you get that cool item
by chance like it's euphoric it's like
if you don't realize you're having that
I mean this is enabling you're gonna go
you're gonna keep playing
yeah games I'm just kidding hey that's
super I just the thing that bothers me
is like yeah these things are going to
make money but not everything that makes
a lot of money has been deemed moral or
good by society yeah and it just it just
was so disheartening to me because it's
like when that's the thing that
determines when money is the thing that
determines everything I'm just like
alright well I like art yeah so the
frigate spinners are pretty cool though
I know but realistically they're pretty
cool that makes sense the woman who like
essentially invented fidget spinners
didn't get a patent so and so yeah oh
yeah so that's just like widespread now
it's a public domain probably way as any
into yesterday more somber mood mmm
yesterday Jason Schreyer over Kotaku I
think he was first one to published like
people have been hearing rumors that a
visceral I wasn't super in the loop with
us that a visceral was kind of in a bad
place to clarify a few years ago we saw
that trailer for Star Wars 1313 you're a
bounty hunter third-person
over-the-shoulder action gears war in
terms of its mechanics but it was very
story driven linear Amy Hennig was one
of the was the creative director
game director on this game and she is
known obviously for a lot of things
and we'll get into that soon because
right now her whatever she's doing is
kind of a hiatus but you know she did
uncharted one two three started on four
she also did some legacy of kain stuff
very story heavy stuff that would have
been into like not obviously not
battlefront multiplayer focused
this guy looks weird now looking back
but 1313 was later cancelled and then it
said eeeh visceral is working on the
story based Star Wars game and then
obviously respawn has something up their
sleeve right now in terms of Star Wars
outside of that VR combat game and also
of course
yeah motive and dice doing Battlefront 2
which releases very soon we just spoke
about the lack of some mobile games yeah
and as of yesterday a visceral was
shuttered by yay and they essentially
Patrick so villain went on record saying
you know it we've had extensive play
testing and we wanted to make a game
with a lot of longevity that people
would keep coming back to in its current
state we need we realized we needed to
revamp this game whatever it was called
didn't have a name or anything it was
just the EA visceral game but
essentially he was saying they want to
make it more of a games of service I'll
pull up the actual quote in the meantime
but it is there currently shuffling
everybody around I'm assuming probably a
lot of people got you know just
straight-up laid off from visceral
everybody else being shuffled around we
don't have a very specific thing to say
very very sad for visceral because I was
very much looking forward to that me and
John Luke just played dead space on
October 13th last week because it was
dead space it's like ninth anniversary
and because that's a fantastic game so
Quinn's dental I just as role as that's
crazy formerly EA Redwood Shores they
did for the ranks Third Age which aha
I'll always gush about they did return
the king they did the first dead space
then they became visceral that does base
to three they did a lot of great stuff
I'm forgetting more I have the list up
but essentially we wanted to talk about
the fact that a linear story heavy Star
Wars game could get shuttered because it
wasn't enough of a game to service that
a Star Wars game could kitchen of all
ip's right right like people were on
Twitter yesterday Nick Chester he does
some PR for epic he was saying like
it sucks but it's not super surprising
even with the Star Wars IP no triple-a
game is a sure thing but of all IPS to
have and for them to say no not even a
Star Wars linear game is enough like if
Star Wars isn't enough what is well you
know what it might not even be that it's
not enough but that they saw a greater
opportunity and they're like well we
have to go for the greater opportunity
yeah yeah a lot Battlefront to loot
crate's and whatnot again we don't know
much about what they're restructuring
this video Gordon Patrick Sutherlands
terminology said they're pivoting which
essentially means that a lot of people
are losing their job and getting right
clearly already going for the Destiny
vibe this again I was saying yesterday
on Twitter and people were like anthem
we already knew was gonna be a destiny
like I was like right but this makes it
even more of a red flag if they were
gonna really lean into this like I was
excited for anthem now I'm just like how
many kind of paywalls am I gonna have to
get by or how many times am I gonna have
to like spend an extra four hours rather
than pay five dollars again that's
speculation we don't know much about
anthem but it's the same publisher and
EA is pivoting toward this kind of
microtransactions stuff elsewhere why
shouldn't I be worried about that stuff
what does this mean about the future of
single-player triple a linear games if
Star Wars isn't even a sure thing I
think it might be too soon to look at
this is like the death knell for
triple-a single-player stuff right I
think there have been signs that have
shown that that's risky for years now we
got Wolfenstein 2 next week we've got
Super Mario Odyssey next week we've got
stuff to look forward to in Nintendo you
can well I would say kind of kind of
branch is its own thing
yeah they own their own platform they
can afford to take risks first file
systems yeah I mean people were bringing
up like well what about Uncharted it's
like uncharted you could take a loss on
the development because that would be
considered a system seller which again
sell more at the first party published
game yeah they're making money up
elsewhere so it's different and Nintendo
I I think it like you really can't
compare them in the same way it's just a
different Leslie but other Japanese
companies you might look at games like
near and persona and be like well look
at those it's like right but the budgets
for those are nothing compared to what
the way
ei star wars no like really here are a
lot of production yeah near was also
yoga taro this cult director there's a
following from the first game they've
been waiting how many years for it but
and again like that's not the most
gorgeous game like you just mentioned
it's not the most like well something
it's got style it's very good it's a
great game but it's not like you said
it's not production value wise as heavy
as battlefront yeah so I'm trying to be
a blockbuster yeah and that's the thing
is like I mean a for a story game I I
feel like the cost for not having it be
a living platform or somewhere that's
going to continue something that's gonna
continue to make money for the company
you kind of can't go for photorealism
because that's just so expensive I mean
I would prefer a stylized art direction
right I mean because that age is better
anyway
there's just like a lot of things that
with a Star Wars game that would drive
the cost up so much that I can see why
they would decide to shut down as
heartbreaking as it is I do want to pull
up the actual so there's a blog post
statement and then Sunderland also
responded to cuts Kotaku Jason try over
there via email with more details but
this is the statement on the blog post
from Sutherland our visceral studio has
been developing an action-adventure
title set in the Star Wars universe in
its current form it was shaping up to be
a story based linear invention adventure
game throughout the development process
we have been testing the game concept
with players listening to the feedback
about what and how they want to play and
closely tracking fundamental shifts in
the marketplace it has become clear that
to deliver an experience that players
will want to come back to and enjoy for
a long time to come we needed to pivot
the design söderling added that visceral
will be ramping down and closing and
that they're in the midst of shifting as
many of the team as possible to other
projects and teams at EA lastly psoralen
said while we had originally expected
this game to launch late in our fiscal
year 2019
I believe EA's fiscal year was like
midway through the year sure we're now
looking at a new time frame that way
we'll announce the future so it could be
fall next year I highly doubt that it
could be 2000 or sorry
it could be fall 2019 could be 2020 who
knows and then he said in the email to
Jason Schreyer when they reached out
regarding the game which was codenamed
Tagg a development team from across
worldwide studios will take over a
development of ragtag led by the ei
Vancouver team that has already been
working on the project alongside a
visceral Steve Anthony will lead this
team and we will use much of the work
that has been done to date by visceral
the assets of ragtag that have already
been built will be the foundation of
this new game so what does that even
mean like the art may be like character
models probably not a structure right
yeah that makes me so mad though not
even guaranteeing that people who were
working on at visceral can be me I mean
I mean you'd have to move to Vancouver
from here which is like another thing
but I mean there's also the question of
was visceral given a choice
right imagine putting four four plus
years of your life in this game and then
that I it's just yeah but if you and
they say this game you're working on we
want to change it do you want to be a
part of that or no yeah exactly
how do you make that call certainly not
blaming visceral for the studio shutting
down of course I'm but it's just one of
those things it's like what is the what
is the total story here we will not know
from this press release that that is not
we can only sir yeah so I was earlier
astonished to send you this this was
like just before we gone stat 12:52 p.m.
yeah pacific desert writer says he the
game was not can because it was single
player from what he's heard yeah he's
heard that it was just a messy situation
overall with the development it was but
the statement that they put out saying
that they've been monitoring the market
they've been heavily focused testing the
game which i get they have to give any
investment risks but [ __ ] all that yeah
that's an easy way to distill something
creative down to something benign yeah
yeah i mean that was like the big thing
once Amy Hennig left uncharted 4 she
didn't like finish out that project of
them she helped in earlier stages we
were wondering what she was gonna be
doing then we heard that she's making a
Star Wars game it was gonna be the
follow-up to be cancelled 1313 it
sounded awesome and it was visceral dead
space I love those games we all be in
evidence yeah and they tweeted that
photo yesterday of the studio that right
there they showed the photo of his
dreams on the staircase if you're
watching this 230 people people yes and
he and Sutherland said as many pieces of
people as possible will we
to other studios so it could be five
could be a me and one other person but
like the thing is like the corporate
speaking you don't know anything yeah
from that statement oh there are the
assets oh great this is great okay good
stuff yeah we're gonna use this
immediately throw it away take a photo
right there thank you Eric Taylor
Richard whoever pulled that up a lot of
people II it's a sad situation we also
want to talk about Sutherland did say we
are in discussions with Amy Amy Hennig
about her next move so I wanted to look
back at miss roles games we're kind of
going along today but we still have some
time left what Amy Hennig has done as a
creative director as an artist as a
writer and also what visceral has done
so I do have like visceral stuff pulled
up and Amy hen eggs but first let's go
see about Amy Hennig so she's been
working games since the late 80s and of
course obviously she's not the only one
that was making the Star Wars game I
think she is the one of the more notable
people especially because that was one
of the drawing point to that game she's
the anchor for the lot of you right
and she's like creatively she's one of
the anchors of I'm trying to
one-two-three the beginning of four she
helped development she's been working
game since late 80s
she became lead designer on Michael
Jordan chaos in the Windy City
damn this Genesis game yes when the
previous quit and yeah and then she
worked on blood omen legacy of kain at
Silicon Knights and then legacy of kain
Soul Reaver Soul Reaver too and legacy
of kain defiance a ton of people always
are calling for the legacy of kain to
come back I never played him really it's
like yeah were they about uh sort of
about like I forget the details but
you're like a demon fighting against an
even worse demon
I see Kane basically as the bad guy you
play as Cain and in the first game but
the second one soul reaver this is the
one that was like this this put the
series on the map this is sort of
defined it it was a you know
third-person action exploration game
where you got some upgrades and stuff
but a really great atmosphere very
interesting sort of conceit for the
story I'm getting crazy crazy nostalgia
vibes on this on this footage like I
remember oh my
there is he's over at Ubisoft now Chris
waters and Andy Bauman but uh former
former GameSpot guy you don't Carlos boy
stur I love jean spot guy yes you worked
in for a while but um yeah I don't know
much about legacy of kain but people are
always saying they would be great to
come back that probably won't happen uh
and then of course honey went to Naughty
Dog she was creative director on Jack
and Dexter a couple of games and then
moved over to uncharted one two and
three as the game director herself
obviously those games were fantastic
uncharted two people always say is you
know one of the better story based games
here's drake's Fortune right here the
first game you could play all these in
the Nathan Drake collection if you want
to to go back to some of Amy's more
recent work before the cancelled 1313
follow up but she has no shortage of
great games in her portfolio and of
course now she's kind of on hiatus they
haven't said much of what she's doing
you know I'm sure she'll land on her
feet somewhere if you know I don't
contractual obligations maybe might make
her go to another EA studio maybe she'll
go to what else could she be doing maybe
leaving yeah yeah and I would tell her
to yeah her next move does not mean her
move with any it doesn't just be there
that means whatever we don't know what
we're doing yet about Amy looking at
what she's good at story based like you
know action-adventure games doesn't seem
like it's aligning with EA's vision
right now well know by me she could
bring those talents to something that
right that's their mold it's just
whether or not she yeah I mean the Fez
de yeah yeah like who's just saying over
the the Mike Saab Bethesda is doing a
lot of single-player stuff between
Wolfenstein - not to assume like fallout
where she falls right in any of those
yeah it seems like there's a talent that
might be wasted at EA somehow and I do
want to go into visceral history because
what a great studio I didn't I
so they began as EA Redwood Shores which
is just south of here
that's just go no double-oh-seven agent
under fire
that's the James Bond game I was playing
on ps2 where you could make the the
hookshot things the defaults so then you
would just hold it it would shoot you up
to a wall
you could hover above everybody to shoot
them and then I had the protect the VIP
mode that's a great game
it wasn't canon James Bond but what is I
can like so clearly here the ricochet
sound in that game yeah it was fantastic
they did lords rings returned the King
the action the character action game
they did Lord rings the Third Age D
Final Fantasy 10 kind of ripoff where
you're following the fellowship
fantastic game if you haven't played it
well your favorite game I promise you
James Bond double seven From Russia With
Love that's the one with Sean Connery on
the cover or young Sean Connery I never
played it sexy Sean Connery yes well he
still is I was gonna say that doesn't
tell me I don't I want Connery alive
yeah I honestly don't know okay they did
the Godfather Godfather - they didn't
come they did my Sims for Microsoft
Windows and we but it Road Rash
jailbreak on PlayStation but of course
in 2008 they did dead space as EA
Redwood Shores the story behind that
game was crazy so Glen Schofield who's
at sledgehammer games now and I named
just gave me this is John Luke's and
mine livestream they did essentially
were at first going to make a System
Shock 3 and then resin before came out
in 2005 and they're like holy [ __ ] this
is really good let's pivot and they
pivoted in a good way
into dead space it was the first like
new IP one of the few IP is at the time
that EA took a chance on very alien
inspired very res named afore inspired
you go aboard the the hand will set in
Astro mo sorry the USG Ishimura mining
vessel in the first game you are Isaac
Clark an engineer kind of everyman no
HUD just all diegetic kind of health
stasis ammunition counter this game is
fantastic it's one of my favorite games
one of my favorite IPs of last
generation people are always saying when
are we gonna get a ps4 Xbox one PC
re-release people are saying there were
some questions I want to get into about
what happens with dead space now if
anything was going to happen but yeah
holy [ __ ] like these games are fantastic
I wish that space is fantastic that
space is one of its it's actually you
can kind of look at dead space as a
microcosm of EA's shift right like the
first three had like microtransactions
oh yes right yeah people people who are
saying it's kind of ironic that dead
space 3 pushed my crotch
actions when it came out 2013 I believe
spring of 2013 I really like that space
to be for what it is very very action
too heavy
shooter cool customization of weapons
and stuff to the crafting is awesome the
crazy weapons you could make you could
put like a bow caster on the bottom with
a rifle on top etc the first game was
way more horror focus slower paced in a
great way it's one of my favorite games
a lot of people love this game this role
is no more so some people were asking
like what will happen with this roles
properties so it's not gonna be so it's
not like EA is not shutting down so it's
not gonna be like th Q's auction it was
visceral own rights to anything yet
right so like I'm assuming the rights to
dead space will just go to if they're
not already under EA those stay at EA
probably under yeah yeah some people are
saying what does it mean for the
possibility of dead space for if there
ever was one I was like they could bring
back dead space for I think would
actually do okay I don't know that
that'll happen for a long time now if it
ever happens I don't think and if they
did it would be microtransaction heavy I
would say didn't though that'll bring
there will be daily challenges and [ __ ]
10-3 have some microtransactions in it
welcome to five minutes yeah sorry
they they kind of they kind of like
sparked my contact they didn't bed
through so much sorry
yes it did you could essentially I never
buy one and stuff to add to the crafting
and whatnot um my bad customer and [ __ ]
I feel like just to say this because we
didn't say it earlier I would much
rather just a studio say a games cost
this game costs eighty dollars flat now
because that's what we need it to come
on I'd rather easy to say we're gonna
cut your budget make your game for more
modest amount of money do it yes yeah I
got hella blade do like a death on this
run or death the outside or do Uncharted
lost legacy double a sized game yeah
we're probably game in half and make it
two parters yes well I was just saying
like instead of microtransactions like
if you need microtransactions to support
the it's like the cost you put into this
game I'd rather just pay more I think
there's probably wider than we imagined
it to be but I'm sure yours I'm sure
yeah yeah so grant willson friend of the
show on Twitter yesterday was saying we
the closure of the studio will some
properties be auctioned to other studios
or stay in house under different teams
for example dead space again THQ auction
happen because THQ itself dissolved yeah
it's still very much a publisher I don't
think anyone's gonna be able to pay you
know EA enough to take a property away
from them when that is just Star Wars
when that is a card they can keep in
their back pocket yeah even something
like dead space I mean there may come a
time when they think that that game is
right and I don't know 10 million 20
million dollars is enough they don't
need that kind of capital it's the
capital isn't the problem it's
opportunity yeah is the problem and they
are they are rich with opportunity and
have the money I sort of dictate how
that plays out yes unless there's any
final thoughts on visceral closing
obviously direction I want to try to end
on a lighter note but underneath final
thoughts I'm excited to see what Amy
Hennig does next cuz she her portfolio
go plate that space one two and three
and tell the devil much you like the
game and I very much feel for everyone
who lost their jobs in the transition
and who put a lot of work into this game
and and maybe feel like it was all for
nothing and I saw a lot people
retweeting job postings yesterday yeah
there's a long shot also if they're
gonna be watching we would love to we're
hiring a video producers know we're
talking I would love to talk to the
visceral people there in the area
they're not watching now I'll reach out
to him separately but I would love to do
something more in-depth down the road
when it's not as fresh well do you like
the silhouette modulated voice thing
[Laughter]
what mule dance called swap and they
don't know yikes
I do let's say that a positive note
jean-luc over the mic which is saying he
would love it Amy Hennig went to
Bethesda Bethesda it was like the chorus
right now in the chat saying people
saying publishers who are doing it right
in terms of balancing stuff like you got
quite champions coming out and I believe
that'll have some sort of payment model
yeah but yeah and you have dishonored
too you have death of the outsider you
have prey arcane I'm very worried about
the problems you're so worried about
repose and say earlier supposed to be a
failure at this point yes you look at
the lineup of those games like right
like Wolfenstein shoes coming out SpaceX
was like an example like it just puts
more pressure on something like
Wolfenstein 2 to sell well because big
publishers do that cascading model money
from dishonour to will go toward prey
prey will go toward you know well
actually I don't know about outside of
arcane but it'll go from project the
project they're not really making a ton
of money on each one especially if
they're flops they're all great games
yeah which gathered they're not all out
for games yeah and but Bethesda in terms
of making games that people do want to
play that still doing a good job right
now I can't say the same thing
commercially praised in - John Luke's
one of our top 5 games of the year but
which sucks and I just beat death the
outsider finally other night like Kelly
to your point like I would love it and
again P you're saying the numbers are
probably we can't even fat on them right
now in terms of what the Delta is but if
I if they were to say hey pay you could
pay $75 for a game like shadow of war
and we're not gonna have know you could
pay $80 for a game like shadow we're
we're not gonna have microtransactions
or you could pay $30 for a game like
hell blade which doesn't cost much money
to make will have a better return on
investment because they're not it's not
a 200 person team working for four years
with thirty million dollars I would love
that if they just widen that and then
gave us the choice between these
double-a sized games indie games are
still personally where I think where a
lot of the creativity is right now
that's what cost to make versus the
amount you can potentially write and
then I think it's I think it's all the
desire to do something interesting and
just let that sort of be it not make
that one interesting thing drawn out to
sort of sell the idea of value I think
value is sort of a sickness and people
who argue about that today don't really
understand how the value of a dollar has
changed and the amount of dollars it
takes to make a game has changed quite a
bit yeah yeah and I really don't like
the idea that that length of a game or
amount of content directly relates to
how impactful it is or how valuable it
is or how much money you should spend on
me for some people it can be if that is
what your measurement of if you can only
afford one game you all right name to
last a long [ __ ] right right I mean
it depends on what you're looking for
right but like for example like star
devalue it was $15 on switch I've
already put like over 30 hours into it
and had it for like what like a weekend
a couple days
versus you know a $60 story like if I'm
just playing the campaign like I used to
I actually used to only really play with
campaigns and call of duty I didn't
really play a lot of multiplayer when I
was younger that I mean they used to be
like what five six hours and then I I
didn't really put a lot of time in for
my money right
yeah and it's it sucks like a novum in
the YouTube chat he's been in the chat
throughout the show was saying the
amount of people buying games has also
changed he can't leave that out right
like I mean the more people the games
are becoming more and more like
pervasive by the day I mean they have
been for quite some time but you know
companies like Activision companies like
EA are gonna say how do we get the most
people to play this game as opposed to
something like cuphead who says how do
we get despite the fact that they sold a
million copies which is fantastic they
you know they sat down they didn't say
how do we get everybody playing games
today to play cuphead they thought how
do we get this these 10,000 people to
play company which is a lot I would
think that's a lot but like you're
making that game for a specific subset
of people and that's great and I feel
like that gap between indie and triple-a
is widen even more it's like triple A's
disappearing it's just becoming these
games as service then everybody else is
saying like if every game is trying to
be a game just service how are you gonna
have time to play all of them like
people who really like we a lot of us
play destiny to a lot but people who
really play destiny to like almost
exclusively play destiny - how is it
gonna be room for a Star Wars game like
that alongside anthem like this makes me
worried about Bioware like how much is
their design be Star Wars I do okay
we're right it'll definitely do okay but
like great who's the stop like everybody
try chasing this I mean even like
gearbox try doing this with battleborn
right I mean we'll actually know that's
kind of unfair they didn't as much and
battleborn is a very underrated gamer
that's a separate separate conversation
my trying every time I hear them it's
just like Chester saying about fortnight
there was like a it's like a hundred
million dollars been to making that game
yes so far and yeah he was due yesterday
right he was talking on Twitter or
something yeah and he was saying like
that was very much a result of epic not
feeling okay about making just a
triple-a like Gears of War game and then
she's releasing it and being $60 it's
more it's more like how do we create
longevity in this game and have you know
like Cliff Bleszinski didn't interview
with Eddie makuu our news editor recent
are
former news editor Chris Perez our news
that are now that he's one of our news
writers that he's already makuu he's our
Eddie makuu he's he's uh he didn't
interview of cliff Lozinski
la Breakers had like we looked on Steam
couple weeks goes how many concurrent
people total no 10 on Steam there was
like that's the second time it's its
surface unlike ready our games look we
did better in it after it like dude yeah
any game yeah like I did 10 when it was
69 concurrence I did see the thing where
somebody was like this is not nice that
was Mark Brown I think oh yeah it was my
breath yes so cliff Lipinski was saying
he's like you know we don't have a huge
player base right now but our whole game
plan was is devoted to increasing the
player base like people aren't the
investments not there cuz games makes so
much takes so much money to make cost so
much money to make sorry and the
investment needs to be a sure thing
almost if you're not making an indie
game with several people like the
moldenhauer brothers makeup head like
Remy Ismail was talking about like stuff
a lot recently on LIXIL and on Twitter
talking about how luftrausers and
nuclear throne were like very much you
know like their structure as a company
allowed them to do something creative
and like cater to a smaller subset of
people but it's kind of sad to see all
this happening that that's super neat
though just like like cuphead is such a
great example of that
we're like that idea like imagine
pitching that to like EA or any
interning like that they're like I'm
sorry what was that out of the border
are you out mm oh yeah right in the draw
game for four years come on
it's what apparently it reminds me of
also the same situation with uh what
happen to Netflix remember hearing that
like the actual story of like the the
creators of Netflix first went to
Blockbuster execs yeah and like got
sworn out like it's still around idiot
yeah are you kidding me I'm blockbuster
yeah let me get up forever mr. Blondi's
very surprised
you guys know what movie passes very
quick tangent movie pass it's blocked no
movie pass you pay for this plastic card
and you get the app per month you pay a
set amount Wow okay you can go see a
movie in theatres each day as long as
it's not opening night I believe and you
can't see more than one movie a day yes
so much per month they lowered it to to
get more people forty bucks no ten
dollars I just got it
dan dragon from Giant Bomb was just like
going off about he's like dude like
someone must have gotten fired for this
because they're so backed up because
everybody just swarmed in to get it dude
if you see one movie a month in anywhere
you're saving money if you see one movie
in IMAX you're saving like $15 a month
if you see a movie each week
IMAX in theaters you're saving like $75
you could go each they don't put you're
making money that's a full-time job yes
but anyway go try to movie pass they're
backed up you need the card but it's
worth checking out before they ramp it
also I would pay $30 for that but maybe
hole that sucks they're like ei doesn't
have the same mindset I mean I would
love to see rather than the the market
kind of being more homogeneous and every
game being games of Sur as service
because I mean like obviously like you
said if you are a destiny 2 player and
that is the game that you play you're
not going to play another game that
attracts that same this is the game that
you play perfect there's very few people
who play like multiple like there's very
few people who like regularly play both
dota and League and then also like
heroes of the storm or something like
this just doesn't make sense even if you
are a mobile player I'd rather see it
diversify and you know something like
cuphead where it's like oh we're not
trying to get everybody to like this
this is for certain people and that's a
great example of something being
successful but like even like I think
about something like gone home that's
like this we're not trying to attract a
huge audience this is an experience for
particular people you don't mean like a
communism would be good for Tripoli this
is just a term okay
you are the fighting game that's the
only one what I'm getting at is it's
just disheartening to see companies jump
on a trend yes when it doesn't
necessarily make sense or translate so I
would money defines the market or
defines the medium when before it was
creativity I can see the headline for
this segment right now is capitalism
ruining Triple A games yes yes ROM
pruning Oh Star Wars great property move
it over to microtransactions I just
season 5 I was playing I was playing
startling yesterday I got a duplicate
very very angry but still great team
very proud of them
ok beautiful that was a long show we are
gonna wrap it up all right let's sorry
John Luke Richard and Eric it's laying
the day we went wait a minute yeah they
don't know who's back there right now
let's talk about South Park
ok let's limit that's what you thought I
was gonna farm I said let's end on a
lighter note didn't you okay I want to
like ask a few reductive questions
because we don't have too much time
South Park do you like to game we put it
up we give it an 8 out of 10 on your
spot but Miguel reviewed it I was
laughing but uh sorry microtransaction
you're good you're good
[Music]
South Park the fractured but whole you
guys are prepared all right what you
guys think of it ok all right all right
so first off just to clarify this just
came out Tuesday from Ubisoft San
Francisco South Park fractured but whole
secret not kind of sequel yes
truth yeah a lot of fanservice for South
Park but instead of like this high
fantasy RPG parody it's superhero new
combat you saying world essentially I
wanna go back and play the the stick of
truth change yeah you are going through
this game right here of course there's a
pooping tutorial and then you do a from
the last game and you have to have some
funny
names for the maneuvers is like did ya
Windsor shuffle or some yeah yeah it's
South Park I think like I don't actually
don't have much to really say other than
like you know like I am actually a huge
South Park fan like easily like of TV
show comedy TV shows just like my like
number two like I freaking love it yeah
whoo a lot of poo jokes in this so yeah
like its its South Park you it's it's
more an interactive south park game all
right
sorry yeah we you so I'm sitting it's
you know it's weird I don't can't really
think of it like any other type of game
per se that is like you're playing it
for South Park you're not playing it for
a game and I want to say that that this
time around compared to last game I
there's a lot more it's this is a lot
more gamey there's a lot more like a
mechanic so surprisingly good like you
know kind of shallow RPG but it was a
good game just like out yeah it was not
like the most well versed South Park fan
so like I guarantee you're getting more
of it than I am but exactly yeah I like
to your point that excites me because I
like to stick up true as a game even
outside of the South Park problem hmm I
sound like this is even more of that
there's a lot more exploration and
heavy-handed like recycling of like
going back to like a garage and and now
using the power that you know like like
gating a lot of of the game of like
chests and like items with your powers
so in that respect I like got frustrated
early on because I was doing a lot maybe
it's too much exploration and realizing
like oh I'm just gonna have to come back
here or fast travel like in this game I
feel like rolls out like really slowly
so you're like walking it just feels
tedious to like walk down the same
street again and again running by these
are the superpowers are pretty funny
you're walking by people whose NPCs that
are random but they aren't voiced by
Trey Parker or like Matt stone which
kind of kills me it actually like I can
like hear a random dude in a vo booth
like that's that's trying to mimic you
know South Park is extremely
like unique humor to those two dudes
right like they are one the same and
it's just like it's kind of it feels a
little disingenuous like yeah but the
other thing I would say is even if like
so then I in my play I can pertain to
just doing the main story the last game
I felt like was was way funnier like
they were I had so many better memories
of the sick of truth than this one I
haven't been this game yet but I would
say that like throughout the course of
the first game like there are so many
scenes that everyone can talk about
right like the going up mister mr.
slave's ass seeing seeing your parents
having sex in the game and like becoming
small and like having like the whole
room rattle eyes are going into like the
nitty gritties are like the walls like
there are a couple good moments but like
I would eat the we're like Randy like
saving Randy on the saucer oh that's
crap people yeah they're back people
love crap people oh yeah anyways do you
like I mean to be reductive again do you
like this better than not stick of truth
is no I like I like so far I've been
liking stick of truth okay
I want to touch on what you said though
about like it not being as funny I
couldn't tell if that was just me
growing out of South Park or getting
over South Park because I mean I I had
definitely like a couple years where I
was like super into South Park and like
really into just Matt and trade in
general and I I know a lot about the
show and it's not like I'm going through
this and I'm seeing those callbacks and
like the the tree the tweek and Craig
joey is like my favorite thing you know
but at some point there's things where
I'm like I get a little exhausted by
certain South Park things like but I
couldn't tell if that was the game or if
that was me I hear exactly what and I
feel the same way I would say it's maybe
a mixture of both
yeah like I feel like I like the front
like for instance like this so
heavy-handed with farts like so
last game but I think even more so again
it's like I just I mean if art will get
me I will laugh pretty hard like when
you die it's like you're dead and then
you got a response so like in-your-face
aggressive that it's funny in that
respect but I don't know like when so
many of the mechanics are like fart on
this person to do this it's like you're
making them throw up yeah like I vent
eventually like it wears thin yeah I
mean there's that there's the I mean
I've never been a big fart humor fan
anyway and the like super like the the
one where like carp the we never should
have gone ziplining whatever that was
there's just a lot of [ __ ] messin with
literal [ __ ] and I just can't watch it
because I'm like there's just too much
actual [ __ ] it's really it's really
funny yeah but like there's there the
South Park you burn that I like is
present in this game like i like the
just those subtle things that remind you
that their children like at the
beginning of the game where you're doing
like a the in truck introductory battle
and the kid in the middle of it there's
like car and everyone has to move
happens all the time during down yeah
and there's that stuff I love what that
is the sad part kimura that I like the
most those things that you're like these
are children and that's horrifying that
these are children saying these things
and doing these things and that's what
but that but there's also the South Park
things where it's like oh that was an
interesting idea and I don't think you
took it far enough like the the
microaggressions battle I thought was
really clever um just the idea of like
what isn't isn't a microaggression but I
just feel like I wanted more of like
well that extreme yeah I know something
with as is usual for South Park they
kind of stay right down the middle with
a lot of things and I just feel like if
they took it just another step and like
actually said something with it I think
that would be funnier to me like if they
really like instead of just being like
haha you can be pansexual in the game
like I just feel like you could do more
with it like I made myself as stem as
possible like I'm eight I have pink hair
and I have literal eyelashes and I'm
wearing a dress at princess Kenny's
dress and like people like it just
doesn't have any impact on and with the
the difficulty slider with the skin
color like it's a very minimal impact on
the game and just
people will be like God's getting urban
in here you know I just feel like
they're just doing that South Park thing
where they just walk walk a line and
crossing the line is just being like
Mexicans and my rights instead of
actually I just feel right they push
boundaries like that's how everyone
knows but oh do you see the Lee South
Park but actually in a safe way I think
it's actually very safe I don't think
it's edgy I think it's edgy humor but I
don't think it's particularly like it
doesn't push any bound you know what I
mean there's like the thing where you
could say something offensive or you
could like actually say something really
funny a funny observation about you know
what I mean like the Mike Rogers thing
was so far enough and it just becomes a
one-off joke that's making light of it
yeah was like such a strawman moment
where it was like I get the joke but
also this is like such a caricature
where I just it's not impactful a little
like in the last game have and I'm
thinking about the last game because
there were so many like oh my god
moments with South Park and like that's
that's what they're known for right
there was like sorry Rob be a dick but
wrap it up quickly great they were like
it was like nazi-like aborted fetuses
right like babies like that was like oh
my god they're I haven't really hit any
of those moments that we saw some
footage of the stripper battle that was
that was edgy but like that was one of
the edgiest moments which it isn't
compared to like other South Park
Roman's yes yeah I mean there's episodes
that I do think do that like I really
like the raisins episode where like
stands really depressed and the Goths
come up to him he's like talking about
like why does anything matter and like
or sorry butters butters is really
depressed of them but is hands-down my
favorite character in South Park and
then he gives that whole speech about
like I'd rather feel this way because
then it means that I felt something
great like I was like holy [ __ ] South
Park like I love that I love that's
where my favorite episodes yes don't
know you're good last point the last
point I have is that like yeah like you
mentioned like you know some of the best
South Park runs run like their kids and
it's
like you know like in real life type
scenarios they said something yeah but
the other thing is that what I think is
kind of absent is that like you'reyou're
getting single characters but like the
best episodes for me are like as you
said butters is my favorite too
butters and Cartman yeah like that
dynamic like there are so many glorious
episodes awesomo like one of the best
episodes ever
yeah my mom super episode is butters
bottom [ __ ] yeah like it's like two
extremes as far as like a kid like you
know carbon just like wrecking butters
yeah in all forms but there's not much
of that yeah that's that's the other
thing I'm missing is like I want more
interactions so it doesn't go far enough
in general to make it worthwhile parody
if you've loved if you like soft part or
you're a huge fan I think you should
totally play this game but as far as the
actual satire goes it's sometimes just
freestyle work in general I want their
satire today I want them to step it up
their satire his Hornets welcome for me
all right that was a long episode almost
an hour and 40 think you've everybody
sticking around we had a lot to talk
about today Sean Luke Richards Randall
said Richard psyche on fire John Luke's
IP Richard Lee and Eric Tay in the back
room thank you for running the show we
do have a giveaway I'll get to that
really quick so we can wrap up and
everybody else can get back to work it
is pretty cool this week it's a lot of
Dishonored we've got a ps4 pro with a
dishonoured skin kind of got the
outsider to mark on it and some cool
stuff on the front of it got Funko pop
we got Corvo and Emily both within and
without their masks and the outsider
himself up there at the top left you
were watching this got the graphic novel
book down lower right there we've got a
novelization dishonored the corroded man
and an art book of Dishonored 2 as well
as an Xbox 1s with said outsider logo
and controller so for specific details
the this giveaway is live right now you
can go follow us on Twitter if you don't
at GameSpot or go to our site the
dishonored 5th anniversary prize pack
will be 5 winners 2 winners will receive
the ps4 or Xbox one custom consoles us
only
apologies people outside that ends this
Saturday October 21st we are also giving
away the Blizzcon virtual tickets so
this will be 10 winners freebies and
exclusive content included this is open
to everyone worldwide this ends Monday
October 23rd so Blizzcon is coming up on
November
Seth 3rd 3rd November 3rd will be
Blizzcon so this is a virtual ticket so
you can watch this all like
live-streaming and whatnot and you'll
also get some swag through that this is
open worldwide this is the same thing go
follow us on Twitter if you don't
already I can't spot retweet it it'll
end Monday October 23rd at noon both and
then again the dishonored 5th
anniversary prize pack and Saturday
October 24 21st at 5 o'clock Pacific
awesome and Shiva if you're defeated
switch at Shiva just posted that link
but again if you're listening to this
after the fact we're watching this half
of fact thanks for joining us for
joining us live on Twitch or YouTube
thank you as always for sticking it out
is fun episode is long but we're glad
everybody it was here we will see you
next week at the normal time 11 o'clock
a.m. Pacific we don't have to push it
back next week so we'll be back to our
morning schedule and who knows maybe
we'll go just as long because there's a
crazy week coming up so we'll see you
then thank you so much for joining
[Music]